who's Randy don't bring anyone love into
this no more son
so anyway Yoshi mentioned that you're
doing some medical testing lately right
are you doing did you say that your film
something I finished one in three months
ago I was going to do another one late
next month it's going to be 36 days I
haven't quantum 36 day yeah this wait a
minute what are you doing I don't know
the drugs but like I always saw only
pant hinged on Monday pay so they just
say is it paying a fortune
well almost 13 grand I think that's
pretty good
oh I think the same columns that stay
how much is the pay I'm very what are
you do you know what they're going to be
testing no but I don't really care per
se most of us only can I care about if
it's anything to do with brain related
like if you have a bipolar or any of
those kind of mental medications I will
not touch those but cancer I don't know
Alzheimer's you've gone for all of it
yeah I've done it yeah
sunny album what will I do to you in 36
hours
what will they do to you in 36 days this
is what typically usually happened I'm
not even concerned by taking the
medication so I'm always like everyone
is starving because they cut selling a
calorie like I got its lowest 116 while
studies I brought back a game like 17
pounds but I already know once I go in
for 36 days I'm going to drop at least
20 to 25 pounds it's like a diet for you
to that's the biggest reason my
brother's enjoy yeah I don't know that's
my number I can still lose weight but
I'm too lazy to lose weight I mean you
did amazing job I mean a lot yeah I lost
I look great thanks buddy I'm lost 50
pounds I've kept it off I actually lost
a couple more pounds since the weigh-in
yeah yeah it's good because you know I
mean you have a lovely wife but most
importantly yeah you have a child you
know yeah yeah and some of my are I
don't want to mention names but some of
the comedian's friend of mine they're
over when I'm just worried about their
kids more than you have Russell yeah oh
sorry
what do we wrestle Peter say he'll he'll
want to do
yeah I am love to have them so Europe I
saw was it but you don't know you don't
know what you're sorry you don't know
what you're getting into for this next
no when do you find out what the drug is
and can you pull the plug on it like if
they show up and you show up on it's
something you don't want to do can you
sing now and leave oh sure that's it so
basically when you you have a like I got
I just emailed them like a money out of
money so that's when I usually email
them and then they'll tell me these are
the following studies we have and then I
love that one I just love the system for
you're like I'm running out of money
what what medical tests you have going
on there's like four or five different
facilities in Southern California huh
and this one this guy always email me
back right away because they're always
afraid even if they pass the screening
they go in after five six day they can't
do any but they just lose their mind
because you can't leave you know and
you're hungry your hands are shaking
because no coffee and caffeine do all
the tests dictate low calorie intake
like no matter what your no so these
these business okay so every
pharmaceutical companies make drugs to
make profit billions of dollars profit
right but it's headed miss but they
don't have a drug to be tested every day
so they have another another business
called CRO clinical research
organization all they do is take a
contact by pharmaceutical company and
say hey we have a X medication we like
to tinsel in people and we need forty
people between this age at this body
mass index and they can't be a smoker so
they have all kinds of different
criteria for each medication based on
each pharmaceutical coming so yes
there's some studies we could drink
coffee great there's other studies where
you could do equally almost anything now
there's other states come so strict you
know no sugar low calorie pain yeah so
those are the ones like so you want to
get forced to diet actually you want you
wanted that's that's one of the major
benefits and when people say like it's
dangerous but like man I feel I feel so
much better when you lose weight I am
good to be skinny feels better so now I
mean here's a question
because you've done so many different
jobs you've had all these chemicals in
you I mean at some point don't you think
that the body is tampered with like
you're not a pure specimen anymore it
has a tabula rasa so to speak you're
you're kind of tainted goods I only feel
like that yeah like you know I had this
conversation two years ago in Vegas and
this guy I don't remember his name at
the party and he was telling me oh my
god whenever that does you're stupid to
do that that's too dangerous and he was
telling me while he was ready to snort
coke so everyone have a different idea
of what's dangerous so you're right I
mean I can't tell you if I were to never
go into this business versus now I'm
taking it two versions of yoshi's which
one would have been the healthy no I'm
not saying that I'm just saying that I
wonder if your body is it good to be but
you're Hannah Nate yeah like because
you've done so many of these like at
what point can you not do them anymore
because you've ingested so awesome age
restriction or are know just chemical
restriction like cuz you like they or
they go thanks guys this guy's been
tested on a hundred medications
therefore you know that's like you can't
do an intercept morning is like too many
miles I'm not saying I did did so again
to it
yeah but many of these organizations
don't talk to each other oh I don't know
they don't know so what happened is
general rule is they wait until thirty
days before they contact you because it
takes about two to three weeks for that
whole medication to get out of your
system so to be safe on one month but
there's times if you're broke you finish
one study you drive across a town I'm
not saying I did it you could drive from
one study to another study and you
barely make it there and do another
screening and hop onto another studies
but there's this group of guys I only do
internal chemical there's group of guys
it's like Fight Club they go literally
city to city next day to stay you know
do studies all over the place I'll see
you guys like oh I remember you 2014
liver cancer study what's up and then
they call me yo4 Yoshi obayashi
I don't know
that guy's mkm whatever so yeah I mean
issue of each other but there's a
circuit and you know all the players a
lot of them yeah I mean it's almost like
when will you go in if you go in for
this one the I I think they're going to
call me within the next seven to ten day
for screening then after they do that
testing well first they make you read
the document document telling you this
page through that right yeah I have to
react well yes only there's only one
facility to test you because if you fail
that test they know that you didn't read
it and they do disqualify other other
place they don't give a there's one
particular so shady even if you get
caught doing something wrong like get
out of the room talk to another person
redo the interview second time around to
pass it they'll do stuff like that I'm
not gonna tell you which one because any
now
[Music]